welcome to a coffee zilla christmas i
come bearing gifts for the children
potentially twenty thousand dollars
worth and i know people say i take
things too far frankly i don't know what
they're talking about guys with
christmas coming up oh my gosh this beer
is so itchy with christmas coming up i
wanted to do something crazy to wrap up
this year which really put us on the map
and which has been so humbling to see
how many people have come to enjoy the
videos and support us so i wanted to
give back something to the shareholders
of zilla to really pump the stuff
to see some dividends before the tax
year ends to end this year with the bank
and no ho ho host i'm married thank you
very much now instead i have something
better than bad puns
coffeezilla is going daily again that's
right all through december bringing it
full circle call your mom call your dad
christmas came early ladies and
gentlemen but listen to me for a second
because there is a catch if you remember
in january we had a challenge i would
shave my head if i missed an upload well
now i'm willing to do you one better not
only will i make the same promise to you
in december but i also have a challenge
for our shareholders we are very close
to 1 million subs the stock has been
going absolutely crazy and i decided if
we hit that goal by december 31st at 11
59 pm i will be donating 10 000 of my
own money to save the children charity
that's right it's an actual charity guys
uh whose name was tarnished by the whole
save the kids saga save the children
actually helps children and i always
thought it would be good if we could not
only call out scams but we could also
help out those in need where we can so
that's if we succeed and hit 1 million
subscribers now if we fail those same
children
are getting call in their stock no i'm
just kidding
uh actually we're gonna donate either
way but only five thousand dollars if we
don't meet our goal so that's the
challenge bump the stock it's free to
like and subscribe and this month it's a
win-win-win no matter what the kids are
winning the shareholders are winning and
i win and you guys are getting content
every single day but wait there's more
i've also decided to add a bonus class a
santa claus if you will to this
challenge to raise the stakes if we meet
our goal before christmas i will double
how much we're donating that's 20 000
to save the children the actual charity
in the name of the godzilla army if we
meet our goal by december 25th so that
means we have to hit our goal by
december 24th at 11 59 pm and yes i know
that's a very ambitious goal but i also
think it's very doable more than half
our audience watching right now is not
subscribed so even if a fraction of you
watching click that button we'd meet our
goal in a single day so that's it that's
the challenge literally everyone wins
it's a fun challenge in the year and uh
you guys will get a ton of content with
special guests starting tomorrow on
coffeezilla's christmas and maybe most
important of all if we meet our goal we
will also find out what's behind the one
million subscriber secret door okay
those are the rules see you tomorrow
[Music]
but things will be different if i was
balling